All those stick-thin models
you see in the magazines?
Look at them for
only 60 seconds,
and they will change your brain.
Hello, hello, friends.
Laci Green here with another
"D News" update for you.
When it comes to men,
society glorifies
being large-- muscles,
height, dominance.
For women, we glorify being
small-- fragility, delicacy,
and the less space you
take up, the better.
The trend is troubling,
and it's notoriously
aggressive with
imagery of women.
These days, we regularly see
images of underweight women
as one of many beauty standards.
In reality, the levels
of thinness we're told
are beautiful can be pretty
dangerous for your health--
things like brittle
bones, constant illness,
ongoing fatigue.
Being underweight is no
healthier than being obese.
The truth is that
seeing these images
affects us in ways that
we don't fully realize.
It's been directly
linked by scientists
to depressive moods,
lower self-esteem,
and eating disorders,
among other things.
But the question has remained.
We know we see this
stuff all the time.
Just how many times can
I look at these images
before they start to affect me?
The answer, according to a new
study, published in PLOS ONE
is one minute.
That's it.
To conduct the
study, participants
were put into groups and primed
with images of plus-size models
or underweight models.
They were then asked to
rate the attractiveness
of manufactured images of
women, with subtly varied BMIs.
They found that those
exposed to plus-size models
found a BMI of 18.4
most attractive,
while those exposed
to underweight models
found a BMI of 16.9
most attractive.
FYI-- anything under
18.5 is considered
underweight for women.
So both preferences
are underweight.
But 16.9 to 18.4 is
quite a leap for only one
minute of exposure.
What does this say about beauty?
One implication is that what we
find attractive is pretty fluid
and it's easily influenced.
We already know this just by
looking at other cultures.
Different cultures find
different features beautiful.
One common example of this
is a tribe in Thailand
that puts a lot of
focus on a long neck.
So they wear these
happy brass rings
throughout their lives that
slowly elongate their necks.
Another place, which is kind
of the opposite of the West,
is Mauritania, where
women are encouraged
to gain as much
weight as possible.
A heavy woman symbolizes
wealth and abundance.
This standard was more common in
the preindustrial west as well.
So when we're talking about
unhealthy imagery as beautiful,
we can shift what's
considered beautiful,
perhaps pretty easily,
by simply shifting
what we portray as beautiful.
In the case of this
study, that would
mean making more sizes of
women visible in the media.
However, that might not
fully resolve the problem.
This was a short-term study.
Many of the more insidious
effects on a person's physical
and mental health happen
from long-term exposure--
seeing the sort of imagery
all throughout their life.
So definitely something to
think about next time you
open one of those women's
or men's magazines.
Thanks for watching, folks.
Be sure to like us on Facebook
for more interesting science
updates.